[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID MUNRO: Good afternoon.
My name's David Munro.
I'm a product manager
at Google Cloud,
and I get to work on Istio.
So first of all, I hope
everyone had a good lunch.
There's nothing like having
the first session after lunch,
because everyone's got
like a nice amount of food
and they're starting to
get into that nice coma.
So let's see if we can wake
you up with some nice YAML
during the course of
the demos and stuff.
Anyway, so we're actually
here to talk about Istio.
We're going to talk a
little bit about, also,
API management on Istio, so
there are a couple of demos
as well.
But first of all, why did
Google actually go around
and actually introduce Istio
as an open source project?
So let's talk a little
bit about the need
for an actual Service Mesh.
So everyone knows
microservices are awesome.
If you think about traditional
applications, monoliths,
you actually have all
your business logic
in one chunk of code.
You pick one language,
you write your code.
To a certain extent, if
your application is small
and your team's small
it's actually easier.
You have one thing to deploy,
you have one piece of code
that's doing many things,
but at the end of the day,
again, it's just
one piece of code.
Where monoliths become
more problematic
is if you need to scale
certain capabilities
within that codebase
independently.
It becomes challenging.
Everyone's working
on the same codebase.
So if you want to
change one thing,
you're still pushing the whole
application, so microservices.
So the benefits around
microservices, your developers
can actually focus on a
specific set of business logic.
You can pick a
language that is more
applicable for that
particular business logic.
So for example, you might use
Ruby to write the front end,
you might use C++ to
write the back end, or Go,
so it gives you a
lot of flexibility.
It also means you can
scale those microservices
independently of each other.
You can also deploy them
And as the developer
of the front end,
I actually don't
need to know anything
about the ETL pipeline.
All I really need to
understand is what interfaces
or what APIs I
need to connect to
and what I need to do
to make that happen.
So it actually
becomes very-- there's
some definite advantages here.
But what happens when you start
to really scale microservices?
You deploy multiple
regions, you actually
have a very large
number of microservices.
You go from maybe five, 10, 100,
maybe to 1,000 microservices.
At that point it becomes
very difficult to actually
understand exactly which
microservice is talking
to which other microservice.
It's hard to understand
if a specific--
you've only got to have
one microservice fail,
and your application,
effectively, is down.
So it's sometimes hard
to determine exactly
which microservice is
causing the problem
or what's going on
within that environment.
Another thing
that's interesting,
too, is if you're writing
these microservices
in different languages,
each implementation
of a given protocol might
be slightly different.
You've got different
developers writing it.
As a result of that, actually
having the same implementation
across the environment
can sometimes
be difficult and
hard to maintain.
So maybe microservices
aren't so cool after all.
There's some challenges
there, right?
As that application
scales, you've
really got to start
working on how
to control that environment.
So what do we do in
this type of industry
when there's a
problem like this?
We developed tools, effectively.
So welcome to Service Mesh.
What is Istio?
So Istio is an open source
project, originally kicked off
by Google and IBM.
It's actually developing
a huge amount of traction.
There's a lot of
interest in Istio.
Has anyone, actually in this
room-- just a show of hands--
obviously, based on
the amount of times
Istio has been mentioned
at Google Next,
I'm pretty sure
everyone's heard of it.
Who's actually used it?
OK, excellent,
there's quite a few.
Fantastic.
And Istio is actually a
fairly broad framework.
It provides a lot
of capabilities.
So let's talk a little bit
about what that actually--
what we can actually
do with Istio.
So it's effectively an
open service platform
that allows you to manage
the service interaction.
So you basically start
thinking about services
first within your environment.
The other key thing
here is it actually
works across both containerized
environments as well
as VM-based workloads.
And it could potentially
be on prem as well as
on cloud or multi-cloud.
There's three main tenants
that Istio provides
from a value perspective.
The first tenant is
related to providing
uniform observability.
With Istio you can
effectively get a common set
of metrics that are
automatically implemented
across your environment without
actually having to do that
from a developer perspective.
The developer now
can just focus on--
you effectively get this
from the infrastructure.
The developer can focus
on the business logic.
You get operational
agility, the ability
to change based on a level seven
context how you want traffic
to traverse through that
mesh and what you actually
want to do with that.
You can also start providing a
policy-driven security posture.
Provide actually your
service-to-service security
as well as--
and this effectively
is infrastructure,
that the infrastructure
can provide you.
Your software
developers now don't
have to worry about implementing
these type of capabilities.
Let's take a little
bit of a closer look.
Istio architectural
components-- this
is, I think pretty much every
Istio presentation I've seen
tends to have this diagram
or something similar to it.
There are three major
control plane components
that's a part of Istio.
Pilot, which we'll
talk about, which
effectively controls your
routing and your forwarding
policy.
Mixer, which is
actually something
that's pretty interesting.
It provides an extensible
model, and we'll talk about some
of the things you
can do with Mixer.
And then you've
got Citadel, which
provides a lot of your
security aspects of Istio.
Let's quickly get through this.
What can you actually do with
security, Istio security?
There was actually a really
good talk yesterday--
I don't know if any
of you got to catch it
but it was a talk about
security in depth.
You know, security is not
just a perimeter problem.
One of the drawbacks or
one of the things you
need to be aware of when
you go to microservices
is now you've actually
opened all these channels
of communication between
services and between parts
of your application.
You need to be able
to lock them down.
So you can use mTLS for that.
We also have the
ability-- and we
do that effectively based on
service identity and channel
attributes.
So it's more than actually
just providing mTLS.
We can also control
the level of access.
So service A can talk to
service B at full access.
Service C can talk to service
B at maybe read-only access.
So you can do things
like that as well.
If you think about
why you support mTLS,
this actually gives
the ability via Istio
to basically do a policy-driven
encryption in transit.
But that's not all.
The other key thing is
around strong authentication,
actually authenticating based
on a strong service identity.
This is important.
So I can actually
make sure that if I
have a compromised service, that
I can't replay that identity
to a different service.
Let's talk a little
bit about Mixer.
Mixer actually provides
really good extensibility.
I can effectively use Mixer to
interconnect to any back end
I want to.
I can use Mixer as a
way to actually pull
in policy into my mesh,
and we'll talk about that.
We'll talk about that
specifically in the context
of API management.
Pilot-- Pilot gives
us the ability
to basically push not only
the routing rules but also
security policy to the proxies,
in this example, Envoy proxies.
This gives us the
ability to do things
like I can do A/B testing.
I can do canary
rollouts, again, all
based on level seven context.
So this is kind of what
Istio, some of the things
that Istio provides.
One of the key
things here is we've
got a little bit of an app.
So we have an app.
This is actually an app that
was also shown at the keynote.
This is the Hipster app,
and this is actually
what it looks like.
So there's around
11, 12 microservices.
Some are written in Go,
some are written in Node.js,
some are written in Python.
But this is just like a typical
little microservices app.
Let's have a quick look at this,
and let's have a look at what
we can do with Istio with this.
So let's transition to the demo.
So here we have
the Hipster Store.
This is everything-- I think
they said on the keynote--
everything the hipster
requires for a good lifestyle.
So I'm going to
actually-- first of all,
I'm going to grab a typewriter,
because I'm actually
going to go and do some typing.
I'm going to need
some coffee, so I'll
get a mug for my coffee.
And then maybe a little
bit of music as well.
I'll add that all to my cart.
Oh, that's-- Wi-Fi
demons have got me again.
OK, so here we go.
Let's see if I can view my cart.
Oh, we're good,
back up and running.
Nothing like Wi-Fi in a
conference environment
to do a demo, just when you
can't possibly be more nervous.
Anyway, so here we go.
So we've actually got
our Hipster Store.
We've placed our order and
we're back up and running.
So let's actually have a look at
what this actually looks like.
So I have a single cluster
running in Kubernetes.
It's just a relatively
small cluster.
On that cluster.
I have a bunch of workloads.
You'll actually see some
of the same workloads that
were actually in
that diagram before.
We have like the front
end, the email service,
but you'll also see a
bunch of Istio components
that are here as well.
The other thing that we can do
is if we drill into one here,
you'll also notice that, OK, so
for this particular service--
I'm actually going to drift
into the pod for a second.
You'll also notice--
I'm doing this a
little bit quickly,
but for this particular
service, we also
have in the same
container, or same pod,
we actually have a sidecar.
So this is effectively
a transparent sidecar
that's running co-located
with that service.
OK, so what can we actually do?
We've got our service running,
our sidecars are all deployed.
Let's actually have
a look at what we can
do from a metrics perspective.
So I'm actually going
to come in here.
I'm going to actually--
I now have a bunch of
standard Istio metrics
that now are just
available to me.
I'm actually using
Stackdriver, but these
could be piped into any
back end that you want.
A lot of people use
Prometheus, Grafana
as their standard
back end of choice.
So you can pick your
I can actually look
at those metrics
very cleanly and very simply.
The other thing
that I can do is now
I can actually get
relational information.
So this is the exact
same application.
Now I'm looking at a
topology view of what
my services are connected to.
So if I look at front end
and I highlight front end,
I can now see my
exact dependency.
The other thing that's
really key about this,
so if you think
about it, now if I've
got a really large
application, maybe you
know hundreds of microservices,
and I'm not exactly sure what
my specific service is talking
to, I can actually use a tool
like this now to
get access to that.
I can also then go,
OK, now I know exactly,
based on traffic, who's
communicating to who
and I can start using that to
lock down my infrastructure,
create my access control
policy for Istio security based
on, now, this dependency graph.
The other thing I can do
is I can actually drill in.
I can start seeing
metrics for that.
Again, very
consistently, I haven't
had to go through and
implement any of this myself
from a software
development perspective.
I can also start
drilling in and actually
have a look at the traces that
exist within this environment.
So that's kind of what I can
see from a metrics perspective.
Now let's actually say, Dave
is a product management guy,
and as a result of that
I like doing experiments.
So the first thing I'm going to
do, actually, is I'm going to--
I see something that says
reconnecting, which doesn't
make me feel very comfortable.
All right, here we go.
All right so we can see the
pods that I've got running.
I'm actually going to
go through and deploy--
someone told me that blue
makes people spend more money.
So I'm actually going
to create a version
of the front end that's blue.
And I'm going to see that
now blue is up and running.
So now let's go back
to my Hipster app.
Now as a product
management guy, I
don't really know
too much about Istio
and how it works
and stuff like that.
So you'll see here that
about 50% of the time I
actually get a blue banner.
Now I actually have
a load generator
running in the background
to get metrics,
so it won't be exactly 50%.
But I don't necessarily
want to do that.
Why would I actually just
roll out a new front end
and apply it to
50% of the traffic?
So now what I want
to do is go, OK,
so let's see how I can
actually limit this down.
I'm actually going to go
through and create a new rule.
So I'm actually going
to create a rules.
This is the YAML piece.
There is nothing like a product
manager using VI and YAML.
[LAUGHTER]
And so fortunately for
me, because I'm actually--
I think the term--
there's a name for
me at Google, it's
called a Greygler,
because I'm old.
And fortunately they haven't
changed the commands in VI
in a long time.
[LAUGHTER]
So it actually still works.
So we've got a rule,
so this is the rule.
We've actually got a rule
that basically defines
what you know gray
and blue would look
like from a policy perspective.
Now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to apply that.
The other thing I'm
going to do is now
I'm actually going to create--
that was interesting.
OK.
So let's actually
have a look at--
so I actually have a--
now I need to actually
apply a rule to that.
So I actually have
a rule here that
has basically everything
now routed to just the gray.
I'm going to apply that
really quickly here.
So I'm going to apply that rule.
Once that is applied, I'll
actually flick across,
and with a bit of
luck, look, we've
actually restored things back
to a nice harmonious state
of everything gray.
So now what I'd like
to do is, OK, I now
actually want to control how
much traffic goes to gray
and how much traffic
goes to blue.
So I actually have,
now, a different version
of that rule that waits.
Now this is actually
where you start
to differentiate from, say,
Kubernetes, for example.
If I had Kubernetes and had
a bunch of different replicas
in the back end, I
can basically only
control the amount
of traffic based
on the number of replicas.
Well, this actually gives me
very fine-grained control,
even though I've only got
effectively two things
on the back end.
So now what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to take that exact
rule, I'm going to apply that.
So now, bit of luck and the
demo gods are on my side,
we should see roughly
one out of two, three--
it seems to be taking
a long time to load--
four, Here we go.
Hey!
Come on, a round of applause,
we actually finally got one.
[APPLAUSE]
Heart rate above 200, not
healthy for a guy my age.
All right, so that's kind
of what I wanted to show.
So basically that was just
like a bit of a canary rollout.
At this point,
I'm actually going
to introduce Nandan to come up.
He's going to actually
talk a little bit about API
management.
So we can actually cross
back to the slides.
NANDAN SRIDHAR:
Thank you, David.
All right, so I'm going
to talk a bit about how
API management fits with Istio.
One of the questions
I get asked a lot is.
If I'm doing microservices,
do I need API management?
Or if I've got Istio
managing my services do
I still need API management?
Well, let's start with
what is API management?
Let's take a simple example.
I've got service
A, and service A
is going to call service B.
If service A and B are really
built by the same team,
then no, not really, you
don't need API management.
You want some
documentation for service B
so it's well documented so
people who wrote service A
know how to invoke it.
But most use cases
are not that simple.
In a very large
enterprise, you're
going to have many, many
teams building services.
Service A and B are not
built by the same team.
The team that built
service B wants
to share that service with
the rest of the organization,
with third parties, with
partners, who knows what else.
So enterprises want to have
a service catalog where APIs
are published to that catalog.
And this is different
from a runtime catalog
that Istio provides.
A catalog that Istio provides
is for Envoy and the sidecars
to find services.
This is more of a
catalog for humans,
for developers to come and
read about that service.
So in addition to
documentation and a catalog,
the next thing that
enterprises would want
is some way of
governing who has access
to which types of services.
So once you onboard a developer,
so some sort of developer
identity is
established, you then
want to control which developer
or developers can get access
to which services.
And as an API provider,
I want to know which
applications consume my API.
Is it the branch application
or is it the call center
application or is
the mobile app?
Which application is consuming
the services that I built?
Who are the developers who
are writing applications
that are consuming my services?
That's the kind of view I want
to have as an API provider.
Some of those APIs
you may even want
to productize and monetize.
APIs are quickly
becoming another channel
through which enterprises are
able to monetize their data.
So when you want to productize
and monetize those APIs, then
again, API management
is important.
So these five factors
help you decide
if a service needs to
grow beyond your team,
needs to be shared
with others, needs
to eventually be monetized, then
API management is important.
There's another aspect.
There are certain
capabilities that you
don't want every single
service provider to build.
There are certain
cross-cutting concerns.
You've seen this in the
form of API gateways
that typically do the job
of rate limiting or quotas.
They do the job of caching.
They do the job of some
transformation mediation.
There are some activities
that you don't want
every single team to build.
So you build some
sort of a service
that they can all leverage.
All these are factors that
go into API management.
So how do they compare?
From our point of
view, you need Istio
to manage all your services.
That could be a database
service, a caching
service, your web pages,
these are all services.
Some of those
services become APIs
when they're shared across your
teams across the organizations.
And at that point you
need API management
to manage those APIs.
So all APIs are services.
Some of those
services become APIs
and you'll need to manage them.
So how, then, do we compare the
capabilities of API management
and service management?
I'm going to go through
a couple of examples.
On the face of it, they have
very similar capabilities,
but when you peel
the layers, you'll
see that there are some
interesting differences.
If you take monitoring
as an example,
service management focus is from
a production operator's point
of view.
They're more interested
in latencies.
They're interested
in error codes.
That's what their interests
are, and to pinpoint
where exactly which
service is failing
or is behaving in a bad way.
But from an API
provider's point of view,
they want to know who are the
top five applications consuming
my service?
That's sort of a
business-centric view
of who are my top consumers?
What will happen if I make
a change to a certain API?
Which applications are impacted?
That an API provider
would be interested in?
Even if you take an
example like rate limiting,
Istio will provide rate
limiting at a service level,
say 1,000 TPS.
That's how much my
service can handle.
But what someone in product
management can decide
is, I want my call
center applications
to get higher priority than,
say, my mobile application.
Because I have
more revenue impact
if my branch services
are not working
as opposed to my mobile app.
That sort of a decision of
prioritizing your requests
can be done through
API management.
And of course there are some
capabilities like monetization
that would only be applicable
within the API management
realm.
So how then do we make
API management work
in an Istio service mesh?
Let's bring you back full
circle to what the Istio
architecture looks like.
This is the Istio service mesh.
Its got all the standard
components and Citadel
or security is not
here, but easily it
could have been in this picture.
You're seeing Mixer,
you're seeing Pilot,
and you're seeing the
sidecar and ingress.
The perfect point to
introduce API management
here is at Mixer.
Mixer is a policy advisor
to the Envoy sidecars.
It tells Envoy when to
allow or not allow traffic.
That's extremely key when you're
enforcing rules or policies.
Also, Mixer is the point that
is collecting telemetry data
that you can ship it off
to your API dashboards.
What you'll see here
is an implementation
of that API management in a
service mesh through Apigee.
Apigee has extended
the Mixer architecture
to be aware of Apigee
API management rules.
So as a developer you can
define those rules centrally
in the Apigee control plane
of productizing your APIs,
defining quotas,
finding entitlements
of who can access your
APIs, also publish
those services to
the developer portal
to determine who can see those
APIs, the documentation for it,
and so on.
And when those services
are now in the portal,
consumers can come
and subscribe to it
and get developer keys
to access that service.
Once you have defined these
rules in the Apigee control
plane, Mixer downloads
that information
and now those
Apigee rules are now
present in the service mesh.
The enforcement now happens
at the sidecar level
or at the ingress
level, depending
on how you have defined it.
So let's take a look at
this with an example.
We had the Hipster app.
Let's say the
requirements changed.
It was mostly a
web-based application
that had a whole bunch of
microservices backing it,
and now we have a
new requirement.
The shipping service there also
allows me to track shipments,
and I want to expose this
tracking API, if you will,
part of the shipping
service externally.
So it can be invoked
not just through the UI
but through mobile app,
through something else.
How would we go ahead
and protect this service?
So that's what we'll
do with the demo next.
Switch to the computer, please.
All right, there it is.
So let's go first and
get the ingress IP
so I can go and access this API.
Let's go to that.
That's going to
store the ingress IP.
Let's make sure I have
the IP address here.
I have my IP address
for the ingress.
Now let's go ahead
and access this API.
All right.
So I got access to my API.
Now that's not a good thing,
because I accessed that API
by providing absolutely
no credentials.
So I want to go and fix that.
So let me go ahead and
apply a rule to change that.
I'll explain in a second
what those rules are.
There are actually three
files here that I'm
going to walk you through.
Two of them you do one time.
This is a one-time setup to
make your mesh API management
affair, if you will.
So the first is a
definitions file.
The definitions file creates
custom resource definitions
that tell the service mesh
what attributes to look for.
So if you're doing
analytics, for example,
what type of
analytics will I want
to be sent to the API dashboard?
I want things like
the request URI,
the path, the type
of service that
was accessed-- there are a whole
bunch of metrics that you want
to collect, and the
definitions file
defines that metric
for analytics.
Similarly, if I'm defining
API keys or OAuth,
where do I look
for these values,
what values am I
interested in is what you
define in the definitions file.
This is a one-time setup up
that the mesh operator does.
Once you're done with that,
the next is the handler.
The handler creates
a configuration
that allows Mixer to communicate
securely to the Apigee Edge
instance.
Within Apigee Edge,
you'd have a tendency
and so you've
defined that, but now
you want some sort of
a secure way for Mixer
to contact Apigee so
it can get those rules.
And the last is when
do I apply this policy?
I've taken a very
simplistic view here.
This last step defines when
do I want this rule applied.
In this case, I
said, well, any time
there's an inbound
traffic, apply these rules.
You may want to be
more selective here.
You can say that,
well, apply this rule
only if the label is
API, or apply this rule
only if the namespace is
API, or something like that.
You can be more
creative with when you
want this rule to be applied.
All right, so now that I
have this rule applied--
oh, that's not good.
Let's try to access
that API again.
I got a permission
denied, quite as expected,
because I applied
the rule that says
now I want to shut this down.
I do not want unauthorized
access to this API.
So now when I try to access
it, it obviously shut me off.
Normally what would happen now
is that this developer would
go into a developer
portal and say, all right,
I see the tracking
API right there.
I'd like to request
access to this.
And this developer
gets an API key
and would use that
key now to access it.
In the interest of time,
I've gone ahead and gotten
one such API key and now
we're going to try and access
this service with my API key.
So same call, but with the
API key, except this time I
am now able to
access that service.
So the Mixer was able
to verify this API key.
It was able to check
against the entitlements.
So first, was the API key valid?
Then, was this API key allowed
to access the tracking API,
and then allow that request in?
Also what happened
behind the scenes--
and you'll see this
in a few minutes--
Mixer sent telemetry
information about this API call
to the API dashboard.
Now more often
than not, API keys
are not sufficient
for enterprises.
They'd like to
secure it with OAuth.
Let's do very quickly, if
we can also do OAuth here.
So I've applied a spec that's
now going to implement or look
for OAuth tokens.
Let's take a look at what
that file looks like.
This is the OAuth spec that I
have for the shipping service.
What you'll see here are
three pieces of info.
One is which service
do I want protected.
That's the shipping
service, that's the target.
And second, what issuer should
I look for in the JWT token,
and you can see the URL there.
That's the issuer
I'm interested in.
And lastly, what's the JSON
web key endpoint I can get?
That's where the
public keys are hosted.
That's hosted in
Apigee at this point.
So how do I verify this token?
Once this policy
is deployed, Envoy
will now check if the
token is expired or not.
And if it is not expired,
the public key is valid.
I mean, does the digital
signature be valid.
But that's one step.
That's almost like the
authentication step.
Make sure that your JSON
web token is reasonable.
But that's every JSON web token
accessing every API, then.
What about the next step?
Can this user access this API?
So now those attributes
are passed to Mixer.
Mixer will still apply the
Apigee rules to say, all right,
is this JSON web token allowed
to access the tracking API?
And that's what we'll see next.
So let's go ahead
and get a token.
So I've got a script here that
will allow me to get a token.
So let's do that and
store it in a variable.
Let's look at that JSON web
token, really long string,
but I'm going to now
parse it and show you
what that looks like.
So let's go put that
in a file so you'll
see what is in that token.
And let's try that.
OK, so you're seeing parts
of that JSON web token
there because what
is inside that token
is the API key or the client
identifier for that JSON web
token.
This then allows Mixer to check
if the JSON web token is really
allowed to access
this particular API,
because you may have a rule
where this client ID can access
a email service, but not
the tracking service.
So that next step of entitlement
check is also done by Mixer.
So let's now call
the same service
using the access token
instead of the API key.
I got back my JSON again.
So what we've been able
to do is to protect
the API while defining certain
rules in the service mesh.
Well, what's also now
interesting to see
is if I can get
this dashboard all
to show up in the API
dashboard, because I
want analytics for it.
So I'm going to refresh this,
and I get hourly metrics, day,
week, and so on.
At the moment, I'm just
going to pick hour.
I have a load generator
running, so you'll
see many more requests than
I actually generated here.
But I can dial down some of
the Istio-specific information
and start looking at the
shipping API, the response
times here and so on, but
also, more importantly,
look at some of the
developer aspects of it.
So who was the developer who
built this shipping service?
How many errors does
this developer generate,
so on and so forth,
is information
I can get by looking
at the API dashboard.
All right, back to the
presentation, please.
OK, so to quickly summarize,
service management
is needed for all your services,
and when you share those assets
with other team, external
vendors, and partners,
API management is
available for you.
Now David for some
announcements.
DAVID MUNRO: So this has
actually been mentioned before,
but Istio 1.0 is literally
right around the corner.
In fact, I think
there's actually even,
on istio.io there's a countdown
clock for the exact time--
[CHEERING]
Exactly, right, so 1.0,
that's a pretty big deal.
We also have managed Istio on
GKE, which is going into alpha.
So if people are
interested in maybe a way
to have a play with Istio in a
GKE environment, let us know.
Please reach out.
We're actually taking
people on that side.
And we also have some
Apigee API integration.
NANDAN SRIDHAR: Yes,
and that's going
to be the GA the same day.
It's just 1.0.
So you guys can look up GitHub.
It's also open source.
[MUSIC PLAYING]